[Music]
foreign
chloe treat thank you for being on the
show
hi thank you for having me michael okay
so just a disclaimer before we start we
know each other very well in fact you're
you're marrying
uh my brother and um so we are
very very close family now uh and
you know i've just been you know you
know my passion for for broadway
and musical theater and theater in
general and that's why i'm just
you know i'm just inspired by what you
and or are doing
and the reason i asked for us to have
this talk is because
you've had the chance to to to
choreograph and direct
so many different shows now from all
different landscapes
from the smallest little from the
smallest little arenas
to you know being to working on broadway
productions
and um as much as i'm curious and
passionate about this world
i know nothing really about choreography
about the direction
and about theater and so for these 20
minutes i want to learn as much as i can
about your work
what are the challenges what is it like
being in theater in
new york in the theater hub of the world
so just
tell me a little bit about yourself
where did where are you from and how did
you even get
to this place where you're at now um
so i am from texas uh and
i grew up as a dancer my grandfather was
in theater so i do have kind of a
theater background
but i grew up as a dancer and then in
high school i had some
injuries and couldn't keep pursuing that
and kind of made a
in retrospect really uninformed left
turn and was like i'll just go to
theater school
um so it was it was a little bit random
and in theater school i quickly learned
that i was not an actor but i got really
lucky
in the program that i was in um
we had to take directing that wasn't
true
in all of the programs but it was true
in the studio that i was um
put into and my very my freshman year
rachel chavkin was my directing teacher
um and for those of you who don't know
who she is she's an incredible
tony award-winning director uh she
recently directed hades town she's the
director of natasha pierre in the great
comet of 1812 and she ended up being
kind of a mentor
collaborator someone i've assisted
throughout my career um
but so how i got into it was kind of
lucky in many ways um and i'm not sure
that if i hadn't been put in that
position
just based on where i was slotted in
school i would have been there
um but yeah so i started directing in
college
um and then the reason that i
choreographed two
is really just because i had a dance
background so i
i feel like choreography um is best when
it's just
one other form that you're using to tell
a story so i think it's really a
director's tool set but it's just
combined with
um information about dance which i had
uh and so that is how i ended up
as a director choreographer so you know
over the past few years i i every time i
thought about about what you're doing
and the transition from choreography to
direction
you know to somebody coming out of the
theater world it just sounds that it's
not the same profession it's different
skill sets
completely and it's it was so weird for
me how you were able to just so quickly
make that smooth transition
is it is it similar at all choreography
and direction
i actually think it's such a similar
skill set i i was also a director
first so i you know before i called
when i graduated school the thing that i
said that i wanted to be doing was
directing
and really just through happenstance
which is a long story that isn't
super interesting i started getting all
of these choreography jobs but it was
never what i wanted to be
but chloe you were a choreographer on
broadway
no i was an associate choreographer on
it doesn't matter who cares but you were
you worked on a bro
you worked on choreography on a broadway
production which is literally
the most prestigious place to be
an associate choreographer whatever you
want to call it but you were in
the highest place you can get to so so
you can't
minimize it and say yeah i was a
director and then i went to to
i mean so i i think it's the exact same
skill set i think it's a little bit like
a square
is a rectangle but a rectangle isn't a
square kind of thing
yeah yeah both titles you have to have
an ability to interpret
stories through the movement of bodies
yeah and so
sometimes like a director deals more in
staging and then you're also in charge
of
how design is telling a story and how
lights and costumes and how all of these
elements are coming together
but that's really what a choreographer
is doing as well they just happen
to have a specific vocabulary which is
dance but it's also just telling a story
through the movement of bodies it's
heightened
um but i think that really the skill
sets should overlap and the kind of
choreography
and direction that i really like and
respond to are when
the choreography is putting the story
first
i i think for theatrical choreography
you know there are a lot of places where
like
flashy choreography for flashy
choreography's sake is great like music
videos and
like if you're choreographing beyonce's
concert like you just want flashy
awesome choreography um
but if you're working on a broadway show
the choreography has to be there to
serve
the story and to be moving the story
forward so in that way it really is the
exact same job of a director you just
maybe have to speak a little bit of this
additional language
um as well i'm sure there's a tech
metaphor to be made there but i don't
know what it is
because i don't know anything about that
okay so tell me what what is directing
i mean you're given a sh you have a show
you have a production that's coming up
um and and what do you what what's day
zero i mean where do you even start
with thinking of a show for example you
were you did spring awakening right
and not not too long ago and you're
sitting there and
how do you even start with that well so
it's really different
if it's a revival or a new piece because
if
if you're directing a new work then
one of the things that you're doing a
huge part of what you're doing
is dramaturgy and is developing the
story and is working with the writers
um because the story is very much still
in progress and you know in a broadway
production for example if a work is new
you're getting rewrites in pre-in
previews so even after the show is open
and has an audience on broadway
you're still making changes all the way
up until opening night so
a new work there's like this huge huge
additional
layer of what you're doing as a director
which is guiding the story changing the
story
um making sure that the story is telling
itself in the best way that it can
um so that's an
added thing that happens on a new work
if you're if you're doing a revival
um you don't have that element but then
you have all of these
all of these additional things which are
like if you're doing a revival
generally there's going to be some kind
of new perspective that you want to
take with it because otherwise you're
just like why
um so then you're thinking more about
directorial concept and why am i wanting
to
retell this story now um
and what about it what what about who i
am as an artist can i
do to look at it through a fresh lens so
so those are kind of two different camps
but regardless um
on day zero you were the person who is
in charge of
coordinating all the different teams so
you're really
the ceo of the company and and there are
writers on a musical there's usually a
book writer a lyric writer
and a composer there's a costume
designer a lighting designer a sound
designer a set designer
there's the cast there's casting and you
are the person
who is making sure that
all of those worlds are speaking
to each other to tell
a story so on day zero as you i mean i
couldn't talk about this for sure so
you're slowly starting to decide what
you feel like this world looks like with
all of your different designers and your
cast
and your team um to move that
vision forward so you know i yeah they
you i mean you're one of the most
creative people that i know and
obviously directing is all about sitting
back and saying how can i put my pers
my my own personality into this but but
i can't help but also
recall when i was in back in high school
and i did some
some musical theater productions i
looked at the director
and i had the most amazing a female
director
leroni okobi who was like a personal
mentor of mine for so many years
and it's a leadership role just as much
as it is a creative role
i mean not just about you know not just
about coordinating the teams which is
a very difficult logistical task but you
have a cast
of people of all ages and you're
you're spending this such an intensive
experience with them sometimes a
different a difficult one because
they're tired they're sick
you have to sometimes give them give
them negative feedback and tell them
listen
what you're doing here is not working so
how much how much are you
preparing for this leadership role and
what are the biggest challenges there
there's so many challenges um uh
you know i think the way that you
prepare for it
is just to do it and practice and and
you know in the theater
theater is really um a community that
still has
um kind of an apprenticeship model um
so you it's very common to assist and
assist and or be an associate for people
for long periods of time so that's kind
of the way that you
train which is that you're in the room
you're not the person leading but you're
watching
and you're like you're seeing what
things you would steal and you're saying
what things you wouldn't do
but then i think nothing really
prepares you for leadership like leading
and then it's kind of
trial and error and
i
the mean that are the most important are
i always want to be the most prepared
person in the room
i don't think i can ask other people for
the calibrating put in the most work
like knowing the most putting in the
most hours being the most prepared
um i feel like that's one of the ways
that you earn respect and can ask a lot
from your team
is if they understand that you're
putting in the work as well
um so that's something that's really
important to me and then i think
uh learning how to especially with
directing where so much of it is
asking people
to interpret something emotionally you
know we're talking about
really subjective things it's it's
trying to pull out a feeling from
someone or it's trying to get someone to
move a certain way
and it isn't objective language it's
often really subjective and i
um one of the things that i think is
practice but is really important to me
is
being a really clear communicator and
finding ways
to speak that are um clear
and focused but also open-ended so that
people don't feel kind of trapped by
them
um and you know i think that i'm good at
it
but also it's hard and definitely there
it's trial and error and you know i have
a cast of
around 30 kind of every six weeks so
it's also like learning
a whole new group of personalities and
everybody responds to different
things and you know so it's just
completely being on your toes and
um being flexible so
you know most jobs in the world are you
know nine to five nine to six even in
the tech world
it's a very structured job usually i'm
not talking about the founder and
entrepreneur but
but usually jobs are structured and you
know where your milestones are for the
week
and and for the day and it seems that
that being in a production especially at
the level that you're at right now
it's not a nine to five job and it's the
intensity
fluctuates dramatically from production
to production and also
on the process of a production so i'd
love to hear a bit about the experience
from your end
what is it like work wise to be director
when are the most intensive times
um yeah you know i have a dear friend
who is also a director choreographer and
she was saying
um she was talking to her therapist
and she was like you're not bipolar but
your life is bipolar
um which i think is really legit for
anyone who's in theater because you
you basically have a new job every six
weeks if you're on creative teams
um and so you go from having nothing
uh which is hard you know it's hard to
have a routine and a life
and and stay kind of consistent you go
from being like i'm in tech i have 10
out of 12
um i work six days a week
that to nothing and it is kind of it
does tend to fluctuate
back and forth that hard um
and you know the other element of it
every production
kind of has a similar flow
in that like you know at the at the
start of rehearsals you're in six or
eight hour days and then in tech it gets
more intense and then there's nothing
but
um part of my life is that i'm a
freelancer so i
constantly also have to be looking for
work um
and i don't usually have a job that
lasts more than
a month so wow that element of it i
think is one of the most
stressful so so
you're what you're touching on you know
that working for for
one month at a time and not really
knowing what's gonna happen six months
from now
and so most people you know you need the
structure and i know about myself that i
i love structure and while i'm excited
sometimes about
not knowing what's gonna happen next
which is what
sort of we're all experiencing now in
terms of corona and that's the next
thing i want to talk about
it's it seems very very scary and you
need a lot of personal resilience and
grit
to not just be a director in theater but
to do any
job in theater because you don't really
know what's happening and
and you have to just stay positive and
keep looking and not take things
personally when they don't work out
right
yeah i mean it's an immense amount of
rejection
you know i think if if everyone applies
for jobs
and doesn't get them and i think even
very talented and successful people
that's a part of their life
but a part of but when you're in theater
you're just always applying for jobs so
the amount of rejection
is is so much more you know i get
rejected a few times a month pretty
consistently
and that is still with my work all the
time so it's not that i'm not getting
things you just get rejected
a lot um and i think anyone in theater
slash any artist i mean i think it i
think it's for
true for most mediums
we cry a lot we go to therapy we do
self-care like it's
it is it's really exhausting and it's
really hard um
and i have seasons where i feel so
grateful for what i do and so in love
with what i do
and like i have endless energy to keep
going
and then i have seasons where it's
really hard and i want to go to medical
school
no no it's crazy so so chloe like what's
happening now
you know i had i was supposed to come to
new york
with my wonderful girlfriend and watch
all these amazing shows and
and all of a sudden everything's
canceled nobody can go to shows
what's happening to the theater world
what do actors do right now like what
what
what do you do right now i mean well
look at the unemployment numbers it's
everyone is suddenly unemployed our our
jobs are defined by
gathering um and on the one hand we're
an incredibly creative group of people
so there's this amazing creativity and
resilience happening and you're seeing
all of these kind of virtual platforms
pop up um you know i had friends who
started this
instagram page theater without theater
that went viral and they're posting
something every night from a show that
closed and
sam pendleton started this thing social
dis dance which is a
like an online dance club and and people
are trying to do
things i'm directing a play reading
online
in the next few weeks but it's not
making up for the
i think it's like a way that we're
feeling not having things to do
and the fact that we're creative but
it's not
paying us you know so on a global level
are things going to go back to normal
afterwards so let's say right now
next week we we social distancing is
over and we can go back to to our
regular life
is theater going to be the same um
you know i think i'm probably not the
person to ask that question i think
that's more like the producers and
and the artistic directors because at
the end of the day so much of it is
about money i think if it ended today
it's been a short enough amount of time
that things could go back
to normal i don't think it's going to
end today
i think you're hearing most broadway
producers
say like all of the show all of the
plays are going to close a few of the
musicals are going to make it through
but not many of them um people's
perspective
from a consumer perspective do you think
the average do you think
because you know in tech a lot of people
are saying we we're so accustomed we're
going to be so accustomed to working
remotely
that my new office might just stay stay
the couch why should i go
travel to an office if i can just stay
here so do you think
people around the world are still gonna
have that passion and drive to go out
to see shows if they can just stay at
home and watch them on tv
like they're doing now i think that
people are going to be so
or at least i'll speak for myself i'm so
hungry to be in a room with people
i feel like actually if there has been a
trend
before this of people being like there's
netflix like i would rather just watch a
story with my pants
off than go to the theater i think
there's a chance that this actually
makes theaters more appealing than they
have
you know there's been a decline in
theater attendance
throughout this century as streaming
platforms and
all other kinds of entertainment become
more available
i hope that this um creates a resurgence
in the desire for live events i i feel
that intuitively inside of myself i
always consider myself antisocial and
inside of this chronovirus quarantine
i'm like i'm social that i miss
people um so i
i if anything i think that
but then there's also just this huge
question
of will theaters be able to stay open
through this
and that's that's not the department
well i'm gonna i'm gonna stick to the
optimistic note that there's gonna be a
resurgence and people are going to
rediscover the energy that's in the
human gathering and sing something live
on stage and not
artificial on the screen and before
before
we leave i have to ask you the last
question
what are three words that you would
describe yourself
three oh my gosh that's so stressful
don't make me do that
you do three words i don't want to do
that
you give two and i'll give one about you
okay
um oh this is so gross it's like a
college application
i mean i won't give you words i'm just
refusing but
i feel like i really believe in stories
i think stories are super important
um and i really believe in doing your
homework and being prepared
those are two things about me i won't
use words
i think i think that's even better chloe
thank you so much
thank you michael that was really great
bye dear